[Música]
bienvenidos a ella soy de france 24 el
fondo de poblaciones de las naciones
unidas encargado de evaluar en el mundo
la salud sexual y reproductiva publicó
su informe anual y encontró que a casi
la mitad de las mujeres en 57 países en
desarrollo se les niega el derecho a
decidir sobre su cuerpo el documento
llamado mi cuerpo me pertenece reclamar
el derecho a la autonomía y la
autodeterminación muestra que casi la
mitad de las mujeres no pueden elegir si
desean tener relaciones sexuales con sus
parejas usar anticoncepción o buscar
atención de salud son tristemente
comunes abusos como la violación la
esterilización forzada las pruebas de
virginidad y la mutilación genital
femenina
precisamente veamos a continuación un
repaso del informe mi cuerpo me
pertenece reclamar el derecho a la
autonomía y la autodeterminación
los datos de la uefa demuestran que
existe un fuerte vínculo entre el poder
para decidir y los niveles educativos
más altos por lo que en los países en
desarrollo sólo el 55 por ciento de las
mujeres están empoderadas para tomar
decisiones relacionadas con la atención
de la salud la anticoncepción y la
capacidad para decir sí o no a tener
relaciones sexuales otro factor que deja
casi a la mitad de las mujeres sin
autonomía corporal es la legislación en
los países y cuando una mujer no tiene
garantías para decidir sobre el propio
cuerpo llegan las violaciones a los
derechos humanos el abuso sexual y la
falta de derechos reproductivos se
vuelven un lugar común y una traba más
para cerrar la brecha de género
se revisaron 57 países en desarrollo y
únicamente el 71 por ciento de esos
países garantizan el acceso a servicios
de maternidad integrales únicamente del
75 por ciento garantizan legalmente un
acceso pleno y equitativo a la
anticoncepción únicamente alrededor del
80% en el leyes que apoyan la salud y el
bienestar sexual únicamente alrededor
del 56 por ciento tienen leyes y
políticas que apoyan la educación
integral en sexualidad
la directora ejecutiva del fondo de
poblaciones de la onu natalia cànem
concluyó que cientos de millones de
mujeres y niñas no son dueñas de sus
propios cuerpos sus vidas son gobernadas
por otros las mujeres tienen el derecho
de tomar sus propias decisiones sobre
sus propios cuerpos la pregunta no es
tienen ese derecho es más bien cuando va
a cumplirse ese derecho hay muchas
maneras en las que se vulnera la
autonomía corporal según la
investigación 20 países tienen leyes que
obligan a casarse con el violador 43
países no cuentan con legislación para
la violencia sexual en las relaciones de
pareja más de 30 países restringen el
derecho de las mujeres a desplazarse
fuera del lugar
las niñas y los niños con discapacidad
tienen casi 3 veces más de
probabilidades de padecer violencia
sexual la solución es el poder de decir
que sí y el derecho a decir que no
y para hablar de los pormenores del
informe nos acompaña la salvadoreña
verónica shimane ella de ser
representante del fondo de poblaciones
de las naciones unidas en colombia
veronica bienvenida a gracias por estar
en ellas hoy y comienzo preguntándole la
autonomía corporal de las mujeres es
violentada todos los días y en todos los
países en este informe que publican
ustedes hacen un énfasis en los países
en desarrollo estamos peor hablemos de
cómo la pobreza nos hace más vulnerables
a las mujeres
sí muchas gracias por el espacio es un
gusto estar acá sí como lo dice el
informe
todos los días se violenta la autonomía
corporal de las mujeres y esto ocurre de
diferentes maneras pero está asociado el
nivel educativo con una mayor y un menor
nivel educativo con una mayor violación
de la autonomía corporal de las mujeres
esto ocurre cuando se casan a una niña
menor de edad cuando se ejerce violencia
sexual cuando se practica la mutilación
genital femenina cuando hay violencia en
las relaciones de pareja cuando hay
coacción reproductiva o cuando hay falta
de acceso a anticonceptivos
y todo lo que son situaciones demasiado
familiares para usted para mí para
cualquier mujer cuando una mujer
veronica no puede decidir sobre su
cuerpo
la consecuencia obvia son las
violaciones a los derechos humanos se
perpetúa la discriminación y en términos
prácticos lo que va a pasar es que se
paraliza el desarrollo de los países
porque
bueno como tú lo dices estamos violando
los derechos humanos pero también
estamos afectando el potencial de esa
mujer o de esa niña a desarrollarse y
por lo tanto afectamos a la familia y a
la sociedad en su conjunto entonces por
eso es tan fundamental abordar este tema
y tan importante que por primera vez se
esté abordando desde el fondo de
población de las naciones unidas para
hacer una reflexión del impacto que la
violación a la autonomía corporal de las
mujeres tiene sobre la sociedad en su
conjunto no sólo sobre los derechos
humanos de las mujeres claro y hablando
por ejemplo de los derechos sexuales y
reproductivos veronica es bastante
irónico como no se nos permite decidir
sobre nuestra propia sexualidad y sobre
la elección a cero no madres pero si
peso sobre la mujer toda la
responsabilidad de la familia y al
atacarla directamente pues estamos es
rompiendo tejido social pero bueno
hablemos precisamente de cómo impedir
que una mujer tome decisiones
al final destruye las posibilidades de
que esta mujer sea funcional en la
sociedad y como esto va a terminar
afectando los territorios
así es el el hecho de que una mujer no
pueda decidir por ejemplo el número de
hijos que quiere tener o el
espaciamiento entre ellos eso va a
afectar el acceso a la educación eso va
a afectar el acceso a un empleo
específico entonces es importante que
tengan acceso no sólo a información sino
que también a servicios y eso es algo
que también nos muestra el informe es
importante que los países cuenten con
legislación que garanticen la autonomía
del cuerpo de las mujeres pero no solo
es importante tener la legislación sino
también que se implemente en los países
y que se implementen para todas las
mujeres sin distinción y para no ir más
lejos hay muchos países en américa
latina que todavía son muy restrictivos
sobre las leyes por ejemplo del aborto y
sobre el acceso que se les da a las
mujeres de anticonceptivos y aquí
quisiera pasar a otro tema
muy delicado verónica y es que todavía
se practican en algunas partes del mundo
estas famosas pruebas de virginidad
sabemos hoy la ciencia nos demuestra que
las pruebas de virginidad no existen y
yo lo que le quiero pedir es que nos
hable de esta mentira que se nos ha
dicho durante tantos años y que debemos
atajar porque nos seguimos viendo
afectadas hay algunos sistemas
judiciales que aún no podrían requerir
que por ejemplo una sobreviviente de
violación se le practicará una prueba de
virginidad para ver si fue o no
violentado
y si esto se da como tú lo dices en
varias partes del mundo
incluyendo en en nuestra región y las
naciones unidas han declarado de forma
categórica que las pruebas de virginidad
violan los derechos humanos y la
dignidad de las mujeres y
específicamente cuando esto se hace sin
el consentimiento de las mujeres
constituye una tortura y una forma de
violencia sexual y como tú ya lo dices
es inútil desde el punto de vista
científico y es una violación de la
ética médica pero se usa en muchas
partes como una forma de promover o
imponer la abstinencia entre las mujeres
solteras y las niñas y hay
justificaciones que van desde la
preservación de la pureza del honor de
la familia hasta la prevención de la
transmisión del vih y el embarazo en la
adolescencia y por eso es tan importante
insistir
en la que las personas y las mujeres
tengan acceso a información y a
servicios de la mejor forma más amplia
posible
mire cosas tan básicas y hay que decirlo
porque pareciera obvio pero
evidentemente no lo es el himen no se
rompe y no necesariamente después de una
primera relación sexual una mujer va a
sangrar y estos son cosas que hay que
tener en cuenta cuando se habla de
derechos humanos y ahora quisiera
preguntarle por otro tipo de violencia
ni siquiera hemos empezado a hablar de
la violencia transfóbica y homofóbica
que existe en el mundo de personas que
se identifican con una identidad
diferente al cuerpo en el que nacieron y
que no pueden sentirse respetados por
esa razón y eso va desde la legislación
de los países y desde la cultura
las 10 hay muchísimos países en el mundo
más de 50 países en el mundo en donde la
relación entre personas del mismo sexo
es penalizada es criminalizada entonces
tenemos un desafío muy importante porque
de igual forma como todo ser humano las
personas transgénero tienen derecho a
tomar decisiones sobre su propio cuerpo
no existe la violencia curativa ni la
violencia correctiva con violencia es
eso no se va a corregir entonces es muy
importante que se reconozca que las
poblaciones de lg y las personas de la
diversidad sexual están expuestas a
estigmas a discriminación a violencias
adicionales incluso cuando buscan
servicios médicos y quizás lo más triste
de todo es que también son víctimas de
violencia al interior de sus propias
familias
muchas veces por falta de comprensión o
de entendimiento
y ya para finalizar verónica como una
gran conclusión después de que tantas
personas a través del fondo de
poblaciones participaron en la
realización de esta investigación para
usted como representante este informe es
un llamado de atención eso es evidente
pero para usted hay un mensaje alentador
o más bien tenemos que preocuparnos
mucho más porque no estamos avanzando al
ritmo necesario
es desalentador bueno creo que yo soy
una persona optimista pero creo que lo
primero para poder resolver un problema
es
y verlo es visibilizar lo entonces este
estudio este informe justamente nos
ayuda a hacer evidente una situación que
muchas veces está naturalizada en ese
sentido y yo veo como un gran avance el
que se esté abordando este tema que
afecta a la mitad de la población y que
es importante primero visibilizar lo
para tomar conciencia y poder tomar
medidas concretas y contundentes que nos
ayuden a cambiar esa realidad aquí
estamos haciendo la tarea que tenga un
feliz día y a ustedes gracias por estar
con nosotros en ellas hoy nos vemos
próximamente
[Música]